[Musique]
même après deux mois les longues files
de visiteurs ne diminue pas
à l'intérieur un fascinant voyage au
japon en thaïlande et ailleurs en asie à
travers des siècles de représentations
culturelles des croyances et de
l'imaginaire
les interprétations de la peur de
l'inconnu sont illustrés par des
peintures des affiches de films des
bandes dessinées mangas et surtout avec
la pièce maîtresse de l'exposition les
zombies des vieux films cantonais
des créatures fantastiques et rentrent à
la recherche du repos éternel
très loin de l'image actuelle des
zombies
[Musique]
l'exposition en fer et fantômes d'asie a
été présentée à paris en 2018 puis
adapté pour le public taiwanais sommet
afin d'inclure des éléments de culture
populaire japonaise et cantonaise mais
aussi du bouddhisme des artistes locaux
taïwanais ont également une place de
choix dans l'exposition d'exposition
s'annonçait déjà populaire mais avant
même son ouverture officielle des
groupes religieux ont dénoncé ce qui a
aidé à sa popularité
certains ont même réclamé son annulation
craignant qu elle ridiculise les
religions ou qu'elle met en valeur les
esprits r
il s'agit simplement de susciter une
réflexion sur les façons d'imaginer et
d'affronter l'inconnu répond-t-elle
en asie les fantômes ne meurt jamais et
le public entretiennent fascination pour
la vie après la mort cette exposition le
confirme ici philippe leblanc
radio-canada thaïlande dans le sud de
taiwan